let's begin this hour with the very
latest on the war in ukraine in a
powerful speech yesterday ukraine's
president vowed his country will not
give up and will not lose its war with
russian invaders ukraine's emergency
services shared this video overnight of
people being pulled from the rubble of a
destroyed house in the city of sumi as
thousands of ukrainians flee the
fighting vice president kamala harris is
scheduled to be in warsaw today to show
solidarity with america's nato allies we
are joined now from germany by retired
lieutenant general ben hodges he was the
commanding general of the us army in
europe between 2014 and 2017. general
it's good to see you again
so let me ask you i think something that
we touched upon yesterday the entire
world is watching the fifth largest
military in the world fighting
ukrainians who were armed nothing with
less than stinger missiles and javelins
um nothing near what the russians bring
to the table and yet they're styming the
russians uh on the streets give us a
sense of the analysis of how the
ukrainians are able to do that
well the ukrainians have a
never-ending resource called heart
a will to defend their own country and
and the russian invaders that are
murdering innocent civilians don't have
that so that that's the key difference
right here is what ukrainian soldiers
and civilians uh what they're doing
versus what the kremlin is is sending
into
ukraine so so we
the i the notion i guess must have been
that putin thought this was going to be
easy he was going to march his troops in
there would be little resistance he
would install a puppet leader in ukraine
and that would be the end of it did they
not have a contingency plan for this
type of urban warfare that we're seeing
where we see grandmothers making molotov
cocktails
yeah it's a gross uh
underestimation of the the fighting
spirit and the will to resist of ukraine
and a gross overestimation of their of
their own talents or their own
capabilities
you know russia began a modern
effort back in 2007 and they've invested
a ton of money into it but even in
modern warfare it's not just technology
that makes a difference it's who's using
the technology how is it being employed
and i don't think that the russian armed
forces have trained actually at the
level and the rigor like you would get
from us military or from the british
military or canadian military to to be
able to effectively do all these things
and so the weaknesses are being revealed
in terms of logistics uh terrible
maintenance
the fact that they don't have sergeants
like we do that can enforce discipline
now that's where we're seeing the
difference and so of course as a result
of this the kremlin has changed their
plan
to a war of attrition which means
they're going to smash every town and
city
to uh create this terrible refugee flow
uh the weaponization of refugees if you
will to put pressure on the zielinski
government and also on other european
governments who now have more than two
million ukrainian refugees uh that
they're taking care of in poland and
other uh central and eastern european
countries
general um you touched on the ground
attack i want to talk about the air
attack yesterday the pentagon rejected
an offer from poland who said that they
would give the u.s fighter jets to
provide to ukraine was it right for them
to turn down that offer for its shipment
of fire fighter jets
nate
this is an excellent question and an
excellent point um i don't think the
book is closed on this yet no okay for
sure for sure ukraine needs the
capabilities to be able to defend
themselves that's all they're asking for
actually they're not asking for american
troops they're asking for the tools so
they can defend themselves poland i
think in a very good uh initiative has
said okay well we can provide about a
third of our air force um for ukraine
because ukrainian pilots would already
know how to fly these particular
aircraft but you know poland understands
um russia and
the idea of them uncovering themselves
to give up a third of their own air
force is not something that they can do
without
a lot of thought and so the idea of
backfilling uh backfilling their air
force uh came about so could the u.s
find f-16s for example somewhere else
whether from another country or or of
their own
i think the issue is in the actual
mechanics of how this would happen
poland said hey we'll hand them over to
the us we'll give them to you at
ramstein air force base our very
important air base in germany
and then let ukrainians fly him into
poland
and i i think this is uh it's not so
simple as we just rejected it there's a
lot of considerations here of
you know us aircraft in germany going to
ukraine
um the russians will not distinguish
necessarily all the
the the mechanics of that general the
mechanics as you're talking about it and
it's actually something that i wanted to
ask you about quickly also because
you've signed a letter with other
foreign policy experts talking about
wanting to support a no-fly zone over
human corridors but that's also a
mechanics or maybe the semantics of it
why would that be distinguishes any
different by putin than another no-fly
zone especially because it seems like
contact really could happen in that
situation
yeah dana you're exactly right and
i did sign that letter because i was so
anxious i am anxious to see us do
something to stop the murder the
deliberate targeting of these
civilian innocent civilians you know we
all are will remember srebrenica july
1995 when 8 000 men and boys bosnians
were murdered by republican cersei
forces while european soldiers on their
u.n mandate stood by and none of us
wants to see that happen again
but it's not inconsequential
the idea that we would do something that
ends up with force on force against
russian forces
for sure
nato air forces would destroy them but
that's not the point the point is what
are the implications for escalation and
keeping the alliance together is
essential so this could not be a us
alone we'd have to get everybody in nato
to agree to it i think most of the
damage is actually being done by rockets
and artillery and cruise missiles fired
from the black sea fleet what can we do
to help ukrainians address the source of
those missiles it's not so much the
russian air force
it's more on the ground as you started
discussing with vlad general hodges we
appreciate the time and the information
the insight thank you